[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online Miranda Lambert shared this sweet
snap smooching her man and fellow
country singer Anderson East captioning
the pic in part thanks for being so
supportive and kind while reality star
turned politician
Omarosa announced on Twitter Saturday
that she and longtime love Pastor John
Allen Newman tied the knot at the Trump
Hotel in Washington DC Wiz Khalifa's ex
Amber Rose posted that video cozied up
to French Montana
aka her Brava while celebrating a
friend's birthday in LA Kylie Jenner
flaunted her assets on the gram
channeling her inner space cowgirl at a
galactic rodeo themed bash and Gweneth
Paltrow wished her son Moses with
Coldplay frontman Chris Martin a happy
eleventh birthday with this rare snap of
the two calling him the love of her life
in the caption natella meanwhile Kelly
Clarkson shared that adorable video of
her daughter River Rose enjoying an
Australian treat
[Music]
you